hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comc they're going to be
going over Larson's opening which is
pawn here to b3 nice little subtle move
again this is kind of a hyper modern
defense meaning White's not looking to
control the center of the board with his
pawns early on instead he's looking to
bring his minor pieces in this case the
bishop from the outside and try to
control the center of the board with his
minor pieces so you know Bishop here to
b2 and usually White has a harder time
getting his dark square really to put a
lot of pressure on the black King so you
know you may see something like Bishop 2
or pawn here to be d4 and then the
bishop comes out but this Bishop is
really you know aiming down on this
darks you know diagonal or it could
always come here to g5 pinning down a
knight sometimes it's on f6
but usually black doesn't have to deal
with you know a bishop here on b2 really
dominating this long dark square
diagonal but that's exactly what white
looks to do in this particular opening
and there's about four main lines that
we're going to be going over today it's
not the most aggressive opening so if
you like kind of a slow build up a nice
attack find these little small
advantages in the opening this is
definitely one that you may want to
check out especially if you're just
tired of playing you know the e4 or d4
you know a lot of times black is very
very prepared for that not always this
prepared for just Larsen's opening of
pawn here to b3 but gives white so many
different options and it's really hard
in my opinion to kind of mess this
opening up because you're not really
committing to anything early on you're
not you know putting a lot of pawns
forward and saying okay what do i do do
I do I take a lot you're really just
kind of building up a nice little
offense so we're going to kind of be
going over some of the four main lines
that you will see and kind of talk about
some of the theory in this opening the
first variation we're going to be going
over is the modern variation which is e
5 and again within the opening there's a
million different possibilities we're
just going to be going over some of the
main lines that you know are pretty
familiar and even if your opponent
hasn't seen the Larsen's opening some of
those common things that okay it makes
less sense they may play a move like
pawn to e5 even if they're not familiar
with a lot of the theory this move
particularly makes a lot of sense
because why it's really trying to
Nate these dark squares and this pawn
here to e5 is kind of counter attacking
and trying to control the center of the
board with this pawn on e5 White's just
going to immediately play Bishop here to
be - that's kind of a constant thing
with the larsson after the pawn here to
b3 fee and cutting this bishop here to
be - again trying to attack the center
of the board
a lot of different ways that black can
respond obviously his pawn is being
attacked so you know it could play a
very passive move like pawn here d6
usually you see something like Knight
here to c6 developing one of the minor
pieces trying to control defend kind of
this pawn here on e5 and then Y can play
pawn here to e3 and this pawn here to e3
you're going to see this in all the
variations that we go over white is
really looking to again control the dark
squares and because of that he can play
a move like pawn here to e3 and then
later play a move like pawn here to d4
you can always come with pawn here to f4
again putting a lot of pressure and he
really doesn't have to worry too much
about his dark square sometimes you may
not want to play this this pawn here to
e3 because then it's going to be harder
for your dark square to get out of the
pawn chain but in this particular
opening white doesn't have to worry
about that so we can freely play pawn
here to e3 and then later push forward
with you know pawn it we had f4 or d4
depending on the situation now black has
a few options one option that you may
see is just pawn here to d5 usually when
you don't try to attack the center of
the board your opponent will freely do
that for you so pawn here to d5 makes a
lot of sense trying to counter-attack
control to sear the board while white
tries to control with his minor pieces
from the outside and white from here can
just play you know Bishop here to b5 why
it's not as concerned with his light
square bishop in this game more
concerned with his dark square so you
know pinning down this night here on c6
makes a lot of sense this is the only
defender on this pawn on e5 so if he can
kind of take that away right now this
Bishop can just come here to e5 and take
because the knight can't take away so
black starts to okay have to figure out
how am I going to now defend this pawn
here on you know ii v he cannot play
something like bishop here
2d6 which makes sense again you know
getting more minor pieces involved into
the game getting ready to castle on the
kingside if you wants to but also adding
a defender on this pawn on e5 since his
Knights not going to be able to do so
why can now play pawn to f4 and again
this is where white really starts to
shine as far as black and make a lot of
mistakes here black can't really take
care with his pawn on f4 because then
the bishop can just immediately come in
here to g7 and since this dark square
Bishop on f8 is gone obviously this rook
here on h8 is going to fall so again
this kind of puts black in a tough spot
as far as how is he really going to
defend you know if he doesn't think
about he just plays a bad move like
Knight here to f6 again this pawn can
just come here gobble up on e5 he's
going to win one of these pieces right
here this night here on c6 is still
pinned down so he can't really defend it
this is definitely going to be bad you
could also see something like Knight
come to e7 getting ready to castle on
the King side but again pawn here to e5
still going to take well I can't really
recapture because this bishop here on b2
is so problematic another move you could
see is Queen down to h4 pretty
aggressive move from from black right
now why can now just play pawn here to
g3 why it's not really too concerned
about castling right now he can always
castle on the Queen side if he wants to
he hasn't really committed too many
pawns so you could play something like
Knight here to c3 later easily get his
Queen evolvement to the game if he wants
to catch on the Queen side so this move
pawn to g3 although it kind of commits
to not castling on the Kings side this
is going to be completely fine if the
Queen comes back here to something like
e 7 you know white can now play knight
here to f3 doesn't want to just take
immediately right now with this pawn
since black now has two defenders but a
move like Knight to f3 adds another
attacker on here so it starts to put
more and more pressure on black so again
these are all going to be very very good
for white again this is in the modern
variation the next variation we're going
to look at is the English variation
which is pawn here to c5 setting up for
you no pawn here to d6 we have Knight
here to c6 well I can always then come
over
Knight to f6 if you wants to and white
has a few different options you can
always play just the bishop here to be
to although against c5 I don't know that
it's really the best line that white can
take but two other options that we're
going to kind of look at are efore and
the very aggressive f4 so the first one
is just e for which kind of goes against
what black is really looking to do which
is dominate the dark squares but this
move of pawn to c5 really just opens up
the door for white to go to a normal
game of you know playing this pawn here
to e4 later playing you know Knight -
you know f3 right here Bishop here - B -
and kind of have kind of a balanced
attack of controlling both the light
squares and the dark squares early on
you can see a move like Knight to c6
which is pretty common kind of that
Sicilian kind of style defense from here
trying to control from this C file and
not really committing anything from the
king side and you know from here where I
could play Bishop here - B - this kind
of gets into it black has a few
different options you know if he plays
now Knight to f6
you know why can push forward with pawn
to e5 a move obviously Black's not going
to come back here to g8 this would be
terrible you lose so much in momentum
tempo wise you can always come here to
e4 but this is a little worse as well
just you know white can now play Knight
to f3 all of his pieces are really
really working well together this knight
on e4 is just really weirdly placed you
could always play something like Knight
here to d5 you know white can continue
with what he was doing Knight to f3 this
is again a stable game right here
white definitely has you know a small
lead you can always bring his light
square castle on the King side this is
going to be fairly good for a white if
we come back here instead of e4 though
another move I like to play is pawn here
to f4 and this is a little bit more
aggressive it really kind of opens up
the door for a stronger attack
especially since black is kind of
committing to this you know Queen side
attack this is kind of opening up the
door for white to push forward on the
Keeney side so you know after a move you
can see Knight here to see
then you could see night here to see 2 F
3 you can see Bishop here to be 2 you
could castle on the Keaney set if you
wanted to and kind of have that Kings
gambit where you know this rook is on f1
and it kind of has a semi-open file once
this pawn comes off the board so really
aggressive attack and one benefit that
White has is he does have this dark
square right here that usually he
doesn't have in his attack so definitely
a few different options from from white
early on again bringing your bishop here
to b2 or if you want to control with E 4
or f4 you have a lot of different
options
the next version that we're going to
look at is the classical variation and
its pawn here to d5 and this is always a
fun game because black says you know
what
I'm going to play my standard opening
I'm going to control the light squares
I'm gonna just let you just dominate the
dark squares and so both sides really
just get to do what they want to do best
and it's just kind of may the best man
win right here so why it's going to
continue with Bishop here - B - no
reason really to go with anything else
right now you can see something like
pawn here to e6 trying to solidify kind
of that pawn chain and then Y can play
this pawn here - II III you know a few
different options right here of what he
wants to do but again this is going to
allow him to play you know pawn here to
f4
he can later play Knight here to f3 he's
just again all these dark squares really
dominating where black really has a lot
of different options you can play you
know Knight here to f6 really control
these light squares he'd always if he
wants to you know play Knight here to c6
pretty common you can always bring his
dark square Bishop involved into the
game but again we kind of block all of
those threats off with you know pawn
here to e3 another reason why we do that
so I get in the classical variation
you'll see it here and there and again
you're just going to continue with what
you're doing control these dark squares
dominate this long diagonal and then
just continue with your normal
development again nothing too crazy no
crazy aggressive lines that you'll see
really in this opening but it's
definitely going to be a solid way to
open for white the last variation we're
going to look at isn't super common but
it's not here to f6 kind of that Indian
variation
style of trying to play a defense with
Knight to f6 and then something you
could play pawn here to g6 being keto on
the you know King side as well you know
right here why it has a few different
options I think one of the best ones is
just here to play you know pawn here two
to d4 I don't think right away playing
Bishop ear to b2 is as strong just
because this long diagonal you're
eventually going to want to get there
but this night here on f6 immediately
kind of shuts down some of your
immediate threat so instead you can just
try to control more the center the board
with something like pawn here to d4
later on you're still going to be
playing that Bishop here to e3 because
your bishops not coming out here you're
not going to be pinning down this you
know this Knight here from from d5 if
you did there's really no reason for
even playing this this pawn here to b2
b3 you're still going to be playing your
Bishop here - to be - you know pawn here
to e3 you're still going to be
developing your light square out here
something like c4 nice little outpost or
you could pin down a piece and then
you're going to get your knight in
bottoms of the game to f3 it's kind of
your standard opening this just is kind
of a stronger attack from from what I've
seen in my experience from black kind of
shutting down some early threats threats
that black has because again now he can
fee in Cato himself he can play you know
pawn here to d6 being head over to f7
castle on the kingside and again it's it
kind of goes into that middle game both
sides are going to be somewhat equal in
the game so again this is the Larsen's
opening it can kind of throw your
opponent off if they're not too familiar
with it so if you want to try something
new give it a go especially if you're
having a hard time getting your dark
square Bishop involved into the game
especially on this long dark diagonal
late in the game it can definitely give
your opponent some problems so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video hopefully
y'all got some of the themes that you
should be thinking about in this opening
hopefully you enjoyed and I'll see you
on the next one thanks for watching